You scratch my back, I scratch yours… because
that’s why we have nails, right?
Hi guys, Lissette here on Dnews.
So, we get a lot of questions from you on
Facebook, on YouTube, on Twitter.
One that got us scratching our heads was Cynthia
Gutierrez’s Why Do We Have Nails?
Well…
The truth is scientists don’t really know
how our fingers came to have flat, thin covers
made of keratin on them.
All we can say for certain is that we have
fingernails because our primate ancestors
had them and they were passed along to us.
For some time, scientists theorized that our
nails were simply vestiges of ancestral claws,
but the scientific explanation has gotten
a lot messier and more complicated that.
Part of the reason it’s complicated is because
nails evolved more than 50 million years ago.
Like most others, this evolutionary trait
evolved slowly through natural selection over
a long period of time.
So scientists must rely on cues - like DNA,
the physical structure and characteristics
of fossils and bones, and phylogeny - where
certain animals fall in the tree of ancestors.
What we do know is that nails on all fingers
are an exclusive characteristic of primates
- though similar keratinous structures like
hooves and horns exist in other animals too.
The earliest evidence we have of fingernails
on primates comes from 55.8 million years
ago, according to a study published in the
American Journal of Physical Anthropology.
Researchers discovered that a small lemur
like primate, less than six inches long, called
Teilhardina brandti, had nails on its digits
- Flat just like ours although they still
retained some claw-like features.
And, like us it was it was an omnivore, but
unlike most of us, it spent a good time up
in trees foraging.
They posit that these nails were more useful
than claws to these little guys in certain
ways - like helping them hold onto smaller
branches - which could mean they would have
been better able to keep their balance a top
trees, which would have helped them forage
for food further, and kept them from falling
off the tree into the hands...uhhh claws…
of a hungry predator.
The fact that these primates with bodies less
than 6 inches long had nails, has seriously
challenged the previous hypothesis that nails
evolved as primates bodies got larger.
By pointing out that these nails gave the
primates an advantage, this evidence also
challenges the idea that we evolved nails
because the rounder, thicker claws simply
became less useful.
Still, it’s important to note that this
does not mean nails are categorically better
than claws, just better for certain things
for certain primates.
Some researchers have even suggested that
the claw to nail relationship is not linear
- that some primates might have lost their
claws, evolved nails, and re-evolved claws
again.
But regardless of why we got them in the first
place - there are a ton of reasons why we
have them today.
Nails are useful in protecting the skin underneath
them and allows us to manipulate small objects
- they can make great little tweezers.
Some scientists also believe they increase
the tactile sensitivity of our fingertips.
And they can also serve as health indicators.
For example, yellow nails could be the sign
of a fungal infection, which is very common
because some fungus loves to eat keratin.
Yellowing could also signal something more
serious like diabetes or lung disease.
And socially, nails have served to indicate
status or style for thousands of years - dating
back to the Chinese royalty in 3000 BCE and
the ancient Egyptians who differentiated class
by the color they painted their nails.
So while the evolutionary role isn’t clear,
it is clear they play an important role in
cultural expression.
Sponsorship
Another way to express yourself is through
a website.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
CTA video
Have you noticed that the nails on your fingers
grow much faster than the nails on your toes?
Trace and Crystal have the skinny on that
here.
Do your nails grow fast or slow?
Mine grow super fast.
We love hearing from you.
If you’ve got a science question, put it
down below and tag it with #AskDNews
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
and remember to subscribe so you never miss
an episode of DNews.
Thanks for watching.